der strikte hallo wundervoll so sie
haben die pressekonferenz
sie haben die pressekonferenz verfolgt
ich fasse mal ganz kurz zusammen es gibt
einmal empfehlungen feiern im
öffentlichen und den privaten raum zu
beschränken mit verschiedenen infektions
hohe höchstwerten einmal 35
neuinfektionen auf 100000 einwohner
einmal 50 neuinfektionen auf 100000
einwohner
dann gibt es genau die die empfehlung
mehr zu lüften das soll auch vor allem
neue anlagen geben in öffentlichen
räumen reisen in risikogebiete sollen
unterlassen werden und das wurde
generell eine große geschlossenheit
betont denn wir jetzt natürlich die
maßnahmen gehen gucken wir erst mal auf
diese feiern
wenn ich als laie drauf gucke scheint
mir das doch relativ kompliziert zu sein
ist das jetzt eine gute idee das wieder
so fein aus zu zitieren dass man im
endeffekt wenn man überlegt ich will
nächste woche geburtstag feiern
eigentlich gar nicht mehr weiß kann ich
noch oder kann ich nicht gut
man muss glaube ich zwei aspekte dabei
bedenken auf der einen seite wissen wir
dass die meisten infektionen zurzeit bei
privaten feiern entstehen und wenn man
da einen grenzwert setzt und sagt man
müsste dann private feiern beschränken
macht es schon erstmals in dort dann
auch die zügel anzuziehen und natürlich
ist aber so ein grenzwert nichts
wissenschaftliches der es fest der der
es einfach willkürlich mehr oder weniger
gesetzt aus den erfahrungswerten die
gemacht hat daher macht es auf der seite
her sinn
auf der anderen seite könnte der wert
eben auch bei 40 oder 50 liegen würden
sie da als virologe es lieber sehen wenn
es deutschlandweit einheitlich wäre so
dass die menschen auf der einen seite in
der handlungssicherheit haben und man
auch sicher sein kann jetzt gibt es
einfach nicht mehr feiern mit mehr als
50 personen öffentlichen räumen zum
beispiel nun man das infektionsgeschehen
wie man ja jetzt auch im moment sieht
ist ja in den verschiedenen
bundesländern sehr unterschiedlich und
wir haben lokale ausbrüche und darauf zu
reagieren das macht schon sinn und auch
dass man sagen
dass man in bestimmten bereichen eben
ein früher ein shut down oder lockdown
macht für eine beschränkung macht werden
den anderen bereichen also in anderen
bundesländern im moment braucht die
infektionszahlen niedrig sind
das macht von meiner seite her sind dass
man das je nach landkreis oder nach
bundesland unterschiedlich handhaben
muss jetzt gibt es ja die andere
maßnahme ist für gastronomien da wurde
angedroht mindestens 50 euro geldstrafe
für den betreiber einer gastronomie bei
falschangaben wenn man sich da auf
diesen zettel einträgt da gab es
natürlich jetzt diese sag mal sehr
offensichtlichen beispiele von donald
duck das ist aber wenn ich mich jetzt
hendrik müller nennen oder sie nennen
sich daniel meier dann ist das nicht so
einfach nachzuvollziehen
halten sie das für eine wirklich sinn
führende und zielführende maßnahme da
den gastronomen zu drohen wenn der
falsche angaben drauf sind dann werdet
ihr zur kasse gebeten
ich hätte mir mehr gewünscht dass man
mehr auf eigenverantwortung plädiert
weil im grunde kann man eine pandemie
nur besiegen indem man gemeinsam daran
arbeitet und es wird ja im januar und
februar und märz genauso auch noch
weiter gehen und wenn wir dann nur mit
dem verboten und verordnungen arbeiten
dann verliert man vielleicht auch teile
der bevölkerung besser würde ich es
finden dass man auch dort darauf
plädiert dass man sagt wir müssen die
verantwortung füreinander übernehmen und
aufeinander acht geben
wieso eine verordnung dann umgesetzt
wird steht noch mal auf einer ganz
anderen seite
und man muss sehen ob diese verordnung
dann auch wirklich so von der polizei
überprüft werden kann
dann gibt es hier den punkt
belüftungsanlagen einmal soll das ein
programm geben 20 21 für mehr
belüftungsanlagen in öffentlichen räumen
da wurde genannt bürgerhäuser schuljahrs
dass es dort quasi zu einer besseren
luft kommt damit sich ein virus über
eurozone nicht so weit ausbreiten kann
da gibt es ja doch sehr unterschiedliche
meinungen ob das tatsächlich zielführend
ist es gibt auch hier bei uns in den
kommentaren kommentatoren die befürchten
das dauert alles viel zu lange bis die
eingebaut sind
wie sinnvoll halten sie jetzt aus
geologischer sicht solche
belüftungsanlagen
nun wir werden die hoch- oder die
höheren zahlen jetzt im
november/dezember wahrscheinlich sehen
daher muss man sehen ob januar dann
nicht wirklich oder 20 1 haben sich
nicht wirklich zu spät ist
in der reaktion darauf und man dass
solche programme dann zu implementieren
dauert dann ja auch ein wenig wir wissen
dass es in geschlossenen räumen wo man
nicht lüften kann viele menschen an
einem ort zusammenkommen dass es dann
schon zur erosion bildung kommen kann
und dann auch zur erosion übertragung
daher ist lüften wichtig und auch
richtig aber ob man durch solche
filteranlagen oder belüftungsanlagen
dann wirklich eine veränderung erreichen
kann
das wird man erst sehen wenn die auch
wirklich installiert worden und das kann
ich mir vorstellen dass das alles sehr
lange dauern wird also im endeffekt
teilweise vielleicht dann auch zu spät
kommt tatsächlich sie haben in einem
interview gerade gesagt der dpa wir
haben es über den sommer hinweg nicht
geschafft pragmatische lösungen zu
finden wie man in bestimmten bereichen
weiter machen kann wenn die
infektionszahlen deutlich steigen sind
diese maßnahmen die jetzt gerade von der
bundeskanzlerin und dem
ministerpräsidenten vorgestellt wurden
sind dass die privat pragmatischen
lösungen die sie sich gewünscht haben
nein ich muss ehrlich sagt sagen leider
nicht es scheint ein bisschen ein
minimalkonsens zwischen den
ministerpräsidenten
denn solche richtwerte wie 35 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner die
hatten wir ja im grunde zuvor auch wir
vergleichen immer noch die werte die wir
im moment haben mit den getesteten
werten oder beschriebenen werten vom
januar vom vom märz und april
die sind aber nicht vergleichbar da wir
wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr
infektionen in dieser jahreszeit hatten
aber die durch die mangel an tests gar
nicht nachweisen konnten jetzt haben wir
die dunkelziffer besser ausgeleuchtet
und sehen das ja eigentlich nur sehr
geringen prozentualen anteil an menschen
auf die stationär oder
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen
das mit einzunehmen einzufassen in die
überlegung ist wichtig in meinen augen
damit
man auch den menschen signalisiert durch
zum beispiel eine ampel wie sich das
infektionsgeschehen bundesweit aber auch
im landkreis erhält das ist zumindest
für mich eine lösung gewesen dass man
auch wegkommen vom allein blick auf die
infektionszahlen zudem wird es wichtig
sein zu sehen wie das mit den test
strategien sein wird wir wissen dass wir
wie wir im moment testen
mittels pcr sehr bald an die
kapazitätsgrenzen kommen werden
es werden viele menschen mit einer
erkältung zum hausarzt gehen oder im
testcenter gehen sie wollen schnell
getestet werden daher hoffe ich dass da
auch bei den test strategien ein mann
umschwenkt und schaut dass man mehr auf
anti gentests oder aber symptom bezogen
und anlassbezogen testungen übergeht der
trick ich gehe gleich nochmal auf die
ampel ein die sie ja auch quasi jetzt
ein bisschen befürwortet haben ich
möchte aber ganz kurz auf unsere
kommentatoren und kommentatoren eingehen
weil ich muss leider sagen ich finde
nicht viel konstruktives in unserer
kommentarspalte auch keine fragen an
herrn schlägt die ich jetzt mal
weiterreichen wollen würde
vielleicht ändert sich das ja noch im
laufe der nächsten minuten ich würde
mich freuen
so jetzt haben wir gerade schon über die
ampel gesprochen und sie haben sie kurz
erwähnt er strikt das ist ja auch ein
lieblingsprojekt von markus söder den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten der hat
sie gerade ich sage mal durch die bande
versucht zu verkaufen hat gesagt dass
das quasi eine ampel was wir jetzt haben
ich habe sie ehrlich gesagt nicht
erkannt aber sein konzept beruht vor
allem auf den infektionszahlen das
berliner konzept beruht auf
infektionszahlen auf der re
produktionszahl und auf der frage wie
viel intensivbetten haben wir was wäre
denn ihre ampel modell was sie
befürworten würden nun wir haben über
die letzten sechs monate sehr viel
gelernt über das infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland und wir sollten in einer
ampel
genau diese daten auch einschließen die
wir gesammelt haben und das auch in
intelligente grenzwerte fassen wir
wissen
die in wir sollten die infektionszahlen
die anzahl der tests damit wir die
positiven rate bestimmen können aber
auch die belegung auf den stationär auf
den stationen und den
intensivmedizinischen stationen mit
einbeziehen dafür können wir richtwerte
setzen an denen wir messen die sich das
infektionsgeschehen verhält also alle
vier parameter zusammengefasst damit wir
sagen können hier bewegen wir uns noch
im grünen oder aber im gelben bereich
das ist auch in der kommunikation dann
einfacher an die bevölkerung dass man
das weitergeben kann
die sich im moment das
infektionsgeschehen verhält ich glaube
es schwer moment einzuschätzen wenn wenn
wir über 5000 oder 6000 neuinfektionen
reden ob das jetzt für den einzelnen
also in der beurteilung als hoch
bedeutet oder aber nur ein leichter
anstieg ist da wirklich ganz gehen wir
noch auf einen anderen satz auf dieses
interview mit der dpa kommen da haben
sie gesagt es gibt zu viel angst wie
kommen sie denn darauf nun die
infektionszahlen sind ja im moment das
worauf wir schauen und die angst besteht
für mich darin dass wir sehr darauf
schauen dass wir das infektionszahlen
anhand dass er die infektionszahlen
niedrig halten und wir gehen im moment
noch davon aus dass wir in einem
bestimmten schwellenwert erreichen dass
wir mehr und mehr die die das leben
zurück fahren
die angst besteht aber darin dass die
infektionszahlen eigentlich nicht mehr
ausschlaggebend alleine sind
denn sind die stationäre belegung wir
sind in einer situation dass das virus
teil des lebens geworden ist wir werden
es nicht loswerden es wird uns auch die
nächsten jahre wenn nicht jahrzehnte
sogar begleiten
auch wenn wir einen impfstoff haben
jetzt zu glauben dass wir das virus
infizieren können dass wir das dass das
virus an einer grenze halt macht dass
wir zu einer normalität zurückkehren
können nur weil wir jetzt den winter so
und herbst so durchmachen ist ein
irrglaube und daher ist es sehr viel
wichtiger von der angst und den
starren auf die infektionszahlen weg zu
kommen sondern dass wir souverän damit
umgehen und auch überlegen wie wir für
einzelne bereiche pragmatische lösungen
aber wenn ich mal eine umfrage vom
hamburg centre of health economics
zitieren darf auch gerade herausgekommen
die ist repräsentativ und demnach halten
sich nur noch 45 prozent der menschen in
deutschland an die abstandsregeln nur
noch 39 prozent an die empfohlene
handhygiene also sich nicht die pfoten
zu schütteln wenn man sich trifft
umarmungen küsschen händeschütteln sind
wieder auf dem vormarsch und auch 58
prozent haben ergeben dass zu vermeiden
die impfbereitschaft nimmt ab das sieht
für mich eher nach abstumpfung und
alltag als nach angst aus und das ist
genau das problem in meinem augen und
ich habe auch sorge dass sich das über
den herbst und winter verschärft wir
sind in einem marathon wir sind nicht in
einem kurzen sprint wo gesagt wird wo
man anfeuert und man versucht schnell
über die ziellinie zu kommen
dieses virus wird sehr lange mit bei uns
bleiben und wir werden auch das besser
bewerkstelligen können wenn es aus einem
eigenen bedürfnis heraus kommt dass wir
aufeinander achtgeben und
eigenverantwortung übernehmen
es ist für mich schon eine angst die die
man das spürt dass wir über androhung
von maßnahmen reden in england verzögern
mit dem militär gedroht
und dass wir darüber reden wie wir
vielleicht teile des lebens wieder
zurückfahren wenn wir nicht auch
gleichzeitig darüber reden wie wir eine
pragmatische lösung für die
verschiedenen bereiche lebensbereichen
finden so wir müssen ein bisschen auch
die zeit gucken vielleicht hat nur noch
eine kurze user frage tatsächlich ist
erstmal fast konstruktives gekommen
herrscht eine ganz praktische frage
nämlich von innen ist er immer auf
facebook ist es sinnvoll sich für den
winter jetzt gegen grippe zu impfen
das glaube ich eine frage die ganz viele
menschen antreibt ist es in jedem fall
sinnvoll sich gegen grippe impfen zu
lassen aus zwei gründen einmal wenn man
gegen grippe game stadt kann man die
grippe nicht bekommen und
leistet sozusagen einen beitrag dass das
infektionsgeschehen herunter gehalten
wird also dass das weniger menschen
grippe und gleichzeitig cupid 19 haben
also das gesundheitssystem entlastet
wird
der zweite punkt dabei ist was wir noch
nicht wissenschaftlich genau
nachgewiesen haben aber es gibt hinweise
darauf dass die grippe-impfungen
zumindest für einen kurzen zeitraum auch
vor einer kurve 19 infektion schützt und
somit weil das immunsystem in einem
alarm zustand ist und dadurch andere
viren er abgewehrt werden
und da vielleicht noch ganz kurz eine
frage von simone vokabular ihrer auf
youtube halten sie es über die
gesetzlichen vorgaben hinaus derzeit für
vertretbar noch feiern in innenräumen
mit 15 oder 30 teilnehmern auszurichten
also überhaupt sollte man auf bayern
möglichst ganz verzichten
das hängt glaube ich sehr vom regionalen
infektionsgeschehen hat wenn man
wirklich einen hohen infektionszahlen
hatte sollte man an sich selber
appellieren oder an seine mitmenschen
und schauen ob es sinnvoll ist eine
veranstaltung im kleinen rahmen oder
überhaupt zu haben oder oder überhaupt
ab ausfallen zu lassen das kann man so
pauschal in meinen augen nicht sagen da
wir ja im moment noch relativ gesehen zu
vielen anderen ländern noch sehr wenige
infektionen sehen
das wird sich natürlich ändern und dann
muss man das auch neu bewerten ob sich
ob bestimmte feierlichkeiten ganz
abgesagt werden sollten
er trägt vielen dank für ihre antworten
und für ihre einschätzungen heute abend
ich bedanke mich für eure kommentare ich
gucke noch habe ich irgendwas finde was
sich tatsächlich lohnt jetzt vorzutragen
weil ich muss sagen so richtig
konstruktiv und gute laune machen das
ist das was ich hier diese leider nicht
so richtig ich kann aber noch mal durch
ihr bleibt ja noch ein bisschen dran
[Musik]
ja ich suche aber ich finde das gar
nicht so viel
das ist schade aber wir geben die
hoffnung nicht auf dass wir vielleicht
doch noch irgendwann in dieser corona
pandemie zu einer konstruktiven
diskussion finden
in diesem sinne das sagen jetzt erst mal
für heute vielen dank fürs zu sehen bis
zum nächsten mal
und tschüss